hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
hearts of Westminster now just six days
ago Rishi sunak was in Belfast it seemed
a deal over the Northern Ireland
protocol was in with was Within Reach
but now things look a little bit more
shaky number 10 insists it's business as
usual with negotiations ongoing is that
true or whatever the truth we're once
again talking about brexit pain for a
conservative prime minister plenty for
us to get stuck into as we bring you
takes from all sides over the next 60
minutes
what I am doing is talking and listening
to the people of Northern Ireland that
is the right thing to do it's to make
sure that we can respond and resolve to
the concerns of the unious communities
and businesses in Northern Ireland and
that is what I will keep doing
the labor leader very kindly said he
would help get any deal through even if
Rishi neck faced a backbench rebellion
the country has to wait while he plucks
up the courage to take home the
malcontents The Reckless the Wreckers on
his own benches but I'm here to tell him
he doesn't need to worry about that
because we will put country before party
and ensure that labor votes to get it
through
but it could be this intervention from
the leader of the biggest unionist party
in Northern Ireland that proved the
trickiest for the prime minister
and will he assure me that he will
address these fundamental constitutional
issues and do so not just by tweaking
the protocol but by rewriting the
legally binding treaty text
well could that demand from Sir Jeffrey
Donaldson prove impossible could it be
the one to Scupper any deal we'll
discuss it all and more with our guests
this evening on the show tonight we are
going to be joined by the security
minister Tom Tucker hat the labor will
be joined live by the shadow prisons and
probation Minister Ellie Reeves
and we're going to be speaking to Jim
Shannon from the Democratic unionist
party much more besides two on take
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening well it looks an
increasingly tricky route for Rishi
Scenic to his hope for deal over the
Northern Ireland protocol with the dep
and plenty of his own MPS too in the way
now on the global stage it's all about
Ukraine just a couple of days until it's
one year since Russia invaded President
Biden is in Europe leading a still
pretty United West while President Putin
is banging the drum at home the fear is
that more anniversaries May lie ahead
well here's the rest of a busy week so
far is the Russian President Vladimir
Putin will make an address to the nation
later this morning where he's expected
to lay out his aims for the second year
of his invasion of Ukraine yes
[Music]
one year ago
the world was racing for the fall of
Kiev
well I just come from a visit to Keith
and I can report Keith Stands Strong he
has two leaders who are moving further
and further apart and digging in even
deeper a year into this war um if you
look at Vladimir Putin's speech it
confirmed our worst fears I think until
the past two days Kate Forbes was seen
as the front runner to replace Nicholas
sturgeon as Scotland's first Minister
now that appears in doubt after she told
Sky News having children outside
marriage is wrong from for me it would
be wrong according to my faith but for
you I have no idea what your faith is so
in a free Society did you do what you
want
I think that we need to remember that
Kate and Hamza religious views we need
to respect that
and if we can't listen to people who
have different views from our own we're
going to be getting into a bit of a
difficult situation do you think this
whatever the person's personal views are
or religious convictions are that they
don't interfere with the policy or
legislative process look I'm a practical
Muslim I don't make any bones better in
a joint statement with the government
the Royal College of Nursing said it was
pausing strike action for intensive
talks overpay and I think this is a
significant step forward every nurse in
England today can breathe a sigh of
relief and more importantly our patients
can I'm very pleased that the government
is in intensive talks with the Royal
College of Nursing to find a way forward
as I've always said we are Keen to
discuss these terms and conditions and
I'm glad that those conversations are
now happening
so that was our usual Montage of the
week so far we can kick off proceedings
this evening by hearing from the
government a little earlier I spoke to
the security minister Tom tugaat I
started with another big story today
that shamima Bagan has lost her appeal
against the home office revoking her
citizenship
who was 15 when she left the UK to join
Islamic state has had her bid to
overturn that decision to strip her of
her British citizenship that's failed so
she can't return to the UK what do you
make of that decision well the guy
welcome the Court's decision but you'll
understand I can't comment more because
there are legal considerations ongoing I
just welcome the fact that the
government has and always will take all
actions necessary to defend the British
people so you welcome the decision you
think it was the right decision look I
welcome the decision I'm afraid for
legal considerations I can't say anymore
how close is a brexit deal
well the talks are ongoing they're
positive uh sort of underlying and the
Prime Minister both said that they are
positive and the Prime Minister has been
in Northern Ireland recently and has
been speaking uh to colleagues across
Parliament uh in recent days as well
because this is a decision not just for
Northern Ireland but for the whole of
the United Kingdom
it's not going to happen is it I'm very
confident the Prime Minister will get
the best deal possible for the country
and that's exactly what he wants that's
by the way also what the T-shirt wants
in Dublin it's also what the president
of the European commission wants in
Brussels I guess the issue is it's not
just about getting the best deal or what
the Prime Minister thinks is the best
deal and I can't comment on that right
because I haven't seen the deal I don't
know how good it is or not but it's
about politics as well isn't it and
what's become abundantly clear is that
the PM hasn't squared off the people he
needs to in order to get this brexit
deal through the dup the Euro Skeptics
in your own party well look I think this
is part of the negotiation right I mean
because the negotiation with the
European Union is about making sure that
we get the best deal with the European
Union and that we get the best
partnership with the Republic of Ireland
going forward and yes of course it means
listening to all voices across the
United Kingdom but it means listening to
all voices in the conservative party of
course it does but across the United
Kingdom means also the communities in
Northern Ireland and that's why the
Prime Minister has invested so much time
so much effort talking to our partners
not just in the dup but in the earth to
unionists and the other parties in
Northern Ireland it doesn't look like
it's paying off though the dep they are
absolutely critical as you and I both
know and I've used them as well to
getting a brexit deal across the line I
just want to play you what Jeffrey
Dalton of the dep said at Prime
Minister's questions today let's listen
and will he assure me that he will
address these fundamental constitutional
issues and do so not just by tweaking
the protocol but by rewriting the
legally binding treaty text
rewriting the legally binding treaty
text it's not going to happen is it well
if the prime minister's answer to that
question was very interesting because he
was entirely complimentary of Jeffrey
and Jeffrey has been somebody who many
of us worked with for a long time in
fact I was in the army with Jeffrey's
brother they've been friends for a very
very long time this is a very important
negotiation it's a very very important
deal and for those of us who are
absolutely passionate conservatives of
course yes but unionists as well
recognizing that the whole of the United
Kingdom needs to be kept whole and
integral in the single Market in the
internal Market of the United
kingdomizing the the both communities
and protecting the goodness the
specifics of what Jeffrey Dalton is
saying right and I get that the tone is
very measured but you have to listen to
the substance not the tone and the tone
he is saying is he wants it Rewritten
the text Rewritten and that's not what
the EU is going to do well what he wants
is he wants an agreement that keeps the
internal Market of the United States he
was very specific about what he wanted
he wants to be reopened he wants the
internal Market of the United Kingdom
held together of course he does he's so
do I by the way he wants to make sure
that the United Kingdom is whole and
integral of course so do I but he also
wants to get over uh the difficulties
that the protocol has been causing at
the moment and he's not alone in that
other parties in Northern Ireland other
parties in the Republic of Ireland and
other parties in the European Union have
also spoken about resolving the
difficulties so I think this is a really
good start for a positive series of
conversations no we're not at a deal yet
that's true but that's exactly what
we're working towards and to have Ursula
vandelion and the Prime Minister saying
positive things I think that's a good
start well again you've got the EU and
the Prime Minister saying positive
things but the problem is that people
back home we need to vote for the deal
the dep have got serious red lines and
it looks very hard to clear and of
course people in your own party as well
the Euro Skeptics too have been
expressing concern about the deal it
does feel like you know know anyone
could have predicted that this was going
to happen anyone paying any attention to
the last five years of Westminster could
have predicted this was going to happen
Sophie it's certainly true that nobody
is going to be surprised that there is a
lot of discussion about it that's
discussions one way of putting it I mean
that's how discussions work I mean
there's a lot of discussion about it
that's absolutely right and the prime
minister is in the process of having
those discussions now what we've got to
do is get to a a position that works for
both communities in Northern Ireland
that's absolutely essential and that
maintains those those essential points
it maintains uh it protects the Good
Friday agreement it keeps the internal
Market of the United Kingdom uh solid
and and and and open and of course it
resolves the difficulty that so many
different people are talking about today
you don't have to be Jeffrey Donaldson
you can you can be Doug Beatty who leads
the Ulster unionist and indeed other
members of different parties in Northern
Ireland who are all talking about this
need to resolve some of those problems
so that's not a that's not a unionist
position it's not nationalist position
everybody's talking about it I just
wanted to listen to what Steve Baker had
to say to me it was a weekend before
Rishi sunak effectively won the
leadership contest he was backing Rishi
sunak but he did so with a very clear
Red Line some would say you know he was
always laying down the law let's have a
listen to what he told me uh there this
is what Steve Baker said the current
policy on the Northern Ireland protocol
must be continued and I think this is
another absolutely crucial point if
say Rishi doesn't or Penny didn't carry
through that policy the Euro Skeptics
would implode the government and again
whatever anyone else may think that my
colleagues like friends like Bill cash
and Mark Francois and John Redwood they
are not going to tolerate any diversion
any equivocation on this point
he's right isn't it the Euro skeptic is
about to employ the government Steve is
a great guy and a good friend and a man
of very high integrity and he is now in
the Northern Ireland office part of
these talks so frankly if we can get
does he support it Steve's part of the
talk Steve is actually in the Northern
Ireland office part of these talks so
Steve will no doubt be making sure that
his voice is heard and the voice of
those people who like him have been on
the eurosceptic wing of the party are
heard and that's really important it's
absolutely fantastic that we've got
somebody like Steve making those points
inside government so that when we come
to having those discussions outside
government with the rest of the party as
you quite rightly say the voices have
not just been heard at the end but
actually right through the process so I
think it's very positive can you say for
sure there will be a vote on this look
the Prime Minister has said today that
Parliament will have his voice heard and
there are many different ways in which
the Parliament can have it does that
mean there will be a vote on any brexit
deal you'll have to ask the chief whip
about that I'm afraid the chief whips in
childhood parliamentary business but the
Prime Minister has been extremely clear
that the parliament will have its its
voice heard and in many ways we're
having our voice heard at the moment of
discussions are being conducted and
we'll we'll have to see what happens in
the end doesn't sound like a yes to me
well you'll have to talk to Chief whip
I'm afraid I know this is being you said
the PM's being clear exactly tell me
it's very clear the parliament's having
its voice heard is it yes what so will
that be a vote but Parliament has its
voice heard at the moment this is the
the discussions that we're having but
that's the point isn't it if you say
that parliament's having this voice
heard now then it's meaningless doesn't
mean that there's gonna be a vague does
it so I'm not gonna I'm not going to
tell you what the what the votes are or
not going to be okay you campaign to
remain uh of course in the EU has brexit
been a success this is the decision the
British people have taken the decision
and what we've got to do is make sure
that it works and the challenge that
we've got at the moment is to make sure
that we resolve those issues in Northern
Ireland in Northern Ireland there are
some very very particular issues you
know them you've covered Northern
Ireland for a lot longer uh than I have
in some ways and and it's absolutely
essential we focus on what those
challenges are and we resolve them
because the Good Friday agreement we're
celebrating 25 years of this year was a
remarkable achievement by some
outstanding people who managed to get
round the table and resolve a problem
that would mean ongoing for nearly 100
years and to see people like Seamus
Mallon and David Hume and David Trimble
getting around that table and actually
making this peace process work giving us
25 years of Peace not just in Northern
Ireland but in London and indeed in Kent
where that deal bomb killed so many
Royal Marines reminds us why this isn't
just about Northern Ireland it's about
the whole of the United Kingdom are you
a bit worried about are you talking very
eloquently about you know the Good
Friday agreement and about the history
in Northern Ireland are you worried that
it's at stake no I'm very positive but
actually what we've got ourselves into
is a situation where these discussions
these conversations are being held
peacefully by elected members not by
gunmen not by militias but by elected
members of various different parties uh
across our islands and I think that's
really important
um I want to talk to you a bit about
Ukraine if I may and President Biden the
U.S president visited Ukraine uh
recently our significant moment was that
I think it's a very significant moment I
think it's it's quite noticeable that uh
a U.S president has gone
to a war zone I can't think of an
occasion when a U.S president has done
that other than to go and visit U.S
troops so it's uh certainly not in
recent uh not in recent years so I think
it's it's it's pretty telling and I
think it speaks to the extraordinary
courage of President zielinski and to
the importance of the Ukrainian people
and the the fight that they are
conducting because they really are quite
literally on the front line of freedom
and we know absolutely that Putin's
Ambitions would not stop in Ukraine were
he to be let through and therefore what
they're doing is they're defending us
all what do you mean by that his
Ambitions wouldn't stop in Ukraine well
let's let's just have a look at the last
20 years
um if you if you go to 2007 for example
you see a very major Cyber attack on
Estonia in 2008 you see the invasion of
Georgia uh in 2000 and I think it was 11
or 12 forgive me I'm going to get it
wrong but a Ukraine an Estonian Border
guard was kidnapped from the Estonian
border and taken to Moscow and put on
trial you see later incidents in Ukraine
whether in 2014 of course the invasion
and the capture of Crimea later attacks
in Montenegro attempted assassinations
attacks in the Czech Republic and indeed
here in the UK the use of a chemical and
a nuclear substance to murder
individuals here in the United Kingdom
now those some of them weren't acts of
War but all of them were warlike acts
and here we are seeing a genuine Act of
War a major element of State aggression
the kind of which we haven't seen in 80
or so years so you say that Ukraine is
on the front line for freedom and of
course early this month presidents
landsky came here to the UK speaking to
MPS I think was the second time he'd
left the country since the invasion and
he had one really clear message he said
that we need Jets is he going to get
them well we've already started training
Ukrainian pilots and I have to say I
think that's an incredibly important
thing to do because what you don't want
to do is make the decision then find
you've got six months to wait until
you've trained the people uh to operate
the mission the equipment so I think
that's a really really important
decision but let's not undersell what
we're already doing since 2014 the
United Kingdom has been training the
Ukrainian Armed Forces we've been
assisting with any number of different
forms of intelligence and sorry cyber
support in terms of the Cyber defense of
Ukraine and we've been making sure that
the Ukrainian people are in the best
possible situation I think anyone would
dispute what the UK has done to this
point the question specifically about
Jets and I honestly don't really know
what the answer is I can't work out if
you're saying yeah it's on the table
because yes we're definitely going to do
it or actually we're just kick it into
the long grass that's not going to
happen what is it are we going to give
Jets that's not a decision we're going
to take right now that's a decision that
we're gonna have to consider but of
course what we've already done and this
is why I think the prime minister's
decision to begin training is so
important is we've already put the
ukrainians in a position where were that
decision on Jets to change they will be
in a position to accept them we have
potentially
um opened the door to giving Jets to
Ukraine we're also sending 14 tanks I
think are we going to backfill them in
our own Army I'm afraid you'll have to
ask the defense secretary about that and
that's going to come up in the
integrated review so I'm not going to
preempt that sure and should there be
more money for a defense in the budget
11 billion pounds and so look I'm I'm an
ex-soldier you're never going to hear me
say no to that question but the reality
is there's a huge number of things we've
got to balance uh at the moment this has
been a really difficult time for the
country you don't need to tell you that
you've been covering it in great detail
and what we've got to do is we've got to
make sure we get a first settlement for
everybody in the United Kingdom but also
that we keep ourselves safe okay thank
you very much thank you
Tom chicken hat uh their security
minister I have a bit of breaking news
to bringing our particularly important
and sobering given the politics that
we're discussing here in Westminster
this evening security sources have told
Sky news that a police officer has been
shot in Omar in County Tyrone that's in
Northern Ireland now the officer has
been taken to hospital because of their
injuries well let's talk a little bit
more about that breaking news uh shall
we and also some of the wider political
story we're covering now we're joined by
our senior Island correspondent David
Blevins
um firstly just bring us the latest that
you know about the shooting our sources
within the Police Service of Northern
Ireland are telling us that one of their
officers has been shot and wounded in an
incident on Kelly clarker Road in Omar
County Tyrone a place many people will
remember because it was where dissident
Republicans carried out the worst single
atrocity of the troubles the bombing the
claimed the lives of 29 people and
unborn twins now there is no in
indication as to what the circumstances
were at this stage but it certainly
would appear to Bear the Hallmarks of a
dissident Republican shooting they have
previously claimed the lives of two
members of the Police Service of
Northern Ireland uh Constable Stephen
Carroll and Constable Ronan care and
along with two prison officers and Two
Soldiers so I suppose it's a vivid
reminder for us as the politics of the
protocol is debated in Westminster that
Northern Ireland 25 years after the Good
Friday agreement is still a divided
society and a place where the pace is
very fragile yeah it's a very important
reminder isn't it as you say we don't
know the details of what's happened but
that place that will be you know burnt
in the memories of so many people and so
important there
um talking about what is going on with
the brexit deal because it felt as
though um we were getting close that
something could be pushed over the line
even this week now it feels like things
are more fragile and of course even more
important in the context that you were
giving us as well what is your
understanding
I think the prime minister is under
pressure on two fronts from the European
research group The Hardline brexitary
element of his own Tory party and that's
because they are unhappy with reported
elements of the deal he has been
negotiating with the European Union he's
also under pressure of course from the
Democratic unionists and if he cannot
get the Democratic unionists on board
then they will not end their boycott of
storm and so Sir Jeffrey Donaldson's
decision is going to be very important
indeed if they don't end that boycott
we're talking about the political
Arrangement that was established by The
Good Friday agreement effectively being
dead 25 years after that historic
breakthrough and they'll be back to the
drawing board so that's the ultimate aim
I think to get stormed back up and
running it hasn't been up and running
since the last election and and that's
the goal for the Prime Minister mistakes
and I have to say listen to Jeffrey
Johnson at primus's questions does it
feel like this is a guy who's about to
be back any deal signed up by the EU
does it I think the dup really got first
indication of what was in this day last
Friday when the prime minister went to
Belfast and that's very unusual through
years of reporting political negotiation
particularly related to Northern Ireland
I've been very conscious of the back
Channel movement while they don't get to
see all of the detail that our
conversations taking place between
government ministers even the Prime
Minister and the dup and their staff
more importantly in the background doing
all of the hard work I understand from
dup sources that hasn't really been
happening which would suggest Rishi
sunak flew to Belfast last Friday hoping
he was going to bounce the dup into this
deal at the last minute that hasn't
happened they weren't happy still
particularly with the European uh court
of justice still having jurisdiction
over Northern Ireland given that it
doesn't have jurisdiction over any other
part of the United Kingdom it's
fascinating hearing you talk about that
you know those channels it's such an
important part of the political process
isn't it just not happening and I do
just wonder you know there are sometimes
a criticism of which you see like that
he's a smart guy but politically he's
quite naive and I just wonder if you
think this is perhaps an example of it
it feels like he's answered the essay
question he's got what he thinks is a
great brexit deal on paper
but you need a bit of I don't know
political Mouse to get it over the line
right well I think that is one of the
concerns that he's been trying to
address the technical issues of there
needing to be a border somewhere as a
result of brexit it was the inevitable
consequence of brexit where were the
checks going to take place some people
were concerned that we were going to see
a return to a border on the island of
Ireland there's been a lot of
campaigning against that particularly by
communities around the Border because
they cross it every day thousands of
times to take their children to school
to go to work to go and visit their
friends it's it's an invisible border
and has been for a very long time now so
the solution to that
under the Northern Ireland protocol was
to establish a border in the Irish sea
instead between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland the very thing that
Boris Johnson said he would never do
promised the dup he would never do was
the very thing he did but that for them
is not just a technical problem it
raises a political question the
Constitutional question of where
Northern Ireland's future lies is it in
a United Ardent or is it in the union
remaining with England Scotland and
Wales it's so fascinating
um
now we've got you we're going to be
talking to DPS Jim and Shannon a little
bit later giving you all kind of
expertise on this area what question
should I be asking him I think it's
fascinating to know that the dup and ERG
rejected Teresa May's deal on brexit uh
but the ERG then backed Boris Johnson's
deal which is which put a line down the
UK established a border in the IRSC and
yet they so they abandoned their friends
in the dup and now they are again
rejecting Rishi sunak steel which has
dismantled um on palatable elements of
the Boris Johnson deal so none of that
makes sense and my question I think to
the dup tonight would be which do you
regret most
championing brexit in the first place
given that it was always going to
require a border somewhere are not
accepting to raise Amaze deal when you
had the opportunity uh really
interesting to have you on the studio a
great privilege for us so thank you very
much David Blevins I'm going to take you
to a break so I can write down the
question that David Blevins has just
suggested that interview with dup coming
up at later are on the program and a
reminder of that breaking news this
evening that security sources have told
Sky news that a police officer has been
shot in Omar in County Tyrone in
Northern Ireland and the officer has
been taken to hospital because of their
injuries
you're watching the take this evening
we're live here in Westminster for you
up next we're going to be hearing from
labor
[Music]
the labor leader at secure starmer torn
to the Prime Minister earlier as we
showed promising he would help to get
any Northern Ireland deal through the
commons if there was a conservative
Rebellion so let's get the view from
labor now shall we with a party Shadow
prisons and probations Minister Ellie
Ruiz I got the sense that Kirsten was
having a bit of fun that prime
minister's questions when he very kindly
offered to you know be the help that
Rishi sunak needed well I don't know if
it's about sort of having fun actually I
think it's about doing the right thing
in the National interest which is why
Kia has said the you know labor Woodland
its support to a deal so that we can get
something over the line that's in the
National interest I think casually right
to offer that support and Labor's right
to offer that
um support seems at the moment the Rishi
soon act seems to be scared of his own
backbenches and that's stopping progress
from being made it's not just being
together in Adventures though is it it's
also taking into consideration the views
of the dep people like to Jeffrey
Johnson who are genuinely concerned
about what it means for the future of
the Union yeah you know I think we've
been having these conversations now for
the past five or six years in Parliament
you know we promised a oven ready brexit
deal by Boris Johnson it's clear that
that wasn't the case it was clear at the
time that that wasn't the case and now
we're continuing to have these these the
these arguments um I think a deal is
there to be done with the European Union
um but it's about getting that over the
line now so you're willing to lend your
votes and to to get that done if it does
mean some of those issues in Northern
Ireland and as you see it would be so
yeah absolutely so what would you say
then to you know we're going to be
interviewing uh the Deep who's Jim
Shannon a bit later what would you used
to say to him someone who has genuine
concerns about you know the role of for
example the European courts on Northern
Ireland or having different rules apply
to different parts of the same country I
mean I think the issue with the the
European court is that you know actually
I think people at the moment in Northern
Ireland more concerned about is
certainty about what's going to happen
getting the assembly up and running
again and things like cost of living I
think people are more concerned about
that actually at the moment than they
are about whether it's the ecj or some
other mechanism that regulates things
and so you know I just think we need to
get something done now we need that
certainty in place we need the assembly
back up and running and that's why we
would lend our support to a deal I'm
Keen to talk as well about shamima begum
and the girl of course who was 15 years
old when she left the UK to join Islamic
State
today she had her appeal and she lost
her appeal to return to the UK to be
allowed to be a British assistant
citizen again it was at the right
decision I'll start by saying it was a
really really troubling uh case
um
she went there at 15 it sounds like she
was radicalized here the judge made some
comments in his judgment today about you
know the fact that there may have been
child sexual sexual exploitation it is
really deeply worrying but there are
also National Security concerns and that
has to be the absolute priority the
hearing was a private hearing because of
those National Security concerns so we
don't know everything that all of the
evidence that was presented at that
hearing
um
I've got the confidence though in the
British justice system about making the
right decisions on these things and
happening we have to respect the
decision that the court made today in
light of those very serious National
Security concerns I guess what some
would say is you know the issues that
you have the concerns about her being a
child when it happened was she groomed
was their sexual exploitation others
would also say even if they were left
sympathetic to her that look this is
also our problem you know she committed
a crime she should return to the UK and
be be tried have a fair trial go to
prison if necessary rather than being
left stateless I mean that's not what
the Court held today and as I say I
think there are these concerns about
National Security and there are things
that you know were heard in court that
we that we don't know about because it
was done behind
um closed out closed doors and I think
that national security issue does need
to be
um the the the priority but look you
know labor has been calling for a long
time for there to be an investigation
into those trafficking elements a
potential trafficking elements and how
you know she came to be radicalized in
the first place
um not just for her case but to make
sure things like this don't happen again
so we have been calling for that as well
and I want to talk to you a little bit
now with your Shadow ministerial hat on
labor has been doing an awful lot about
um crime this week there's been a lot as
well of a focus on violence against
women and girls in light of people's
faith in the metropolitan police as well
you know if you are you know a woman who
has experienced a sexual crime why
should you trust in that place
and I think actually confidence in the
metropolitan police amongst women is a
an all-time low
um
you know we had the shocking case of
David Carrick Wayne cousins as well and
confidence is really really low in the
police and I think the new met Police
Commissioner has got a huge amount of
work to do to restraw trust and
confidence of women in London and their
faith in police but there's also a lot
more I think that the government could
be doing
um in terms of tackling violence against
women and girls because it feels like
it's something that has become almost
epidemic in society you know every day
you read the news and you hear about
um another woman being murdered or you
know another case of uh domestic abuse
or serious sexual violence and it does
feel like not enough is being done to
tackle that a lot of people talk as well
about the conviction rates right and
very low chance if if you report a
sexual crime that they actually been
seeing the the perpetration being
brought Justice I mean are you worried
that you know rape is always becoming
decriminalized I'm really worried about
that um something like 1.6 of reported
rapes result in a charge or a summons
um so it's incredibly low numbers
there's also been a big issue about how
long it's taking cases to get to court
so the average weight for rape victims
waiting for their case to get to court
has gone up to three years three years
when someone's life is on hold where
they're suffering trauma they've got it
hanging over them and actually the
dropout rate is is really high for rape
cases because of that because people
want to move on with their lives and
women tell me that they they don't feel
supported by the system they often feel
like it's working against them rather
than rather than for them and the final
question I got for you um I normally
hate these kind of anecdotal things but
I actually got checked into this guy a
couple of weeks ago and what he said to
me really stayed with me he was like
look you know
we're talking rightly all the time about
women and girls and the Met police but
what we're not talking about enough is
race and he said that we should be
talking much more about how black men in
particular are treated by the police and
his own Community is distrust of the Met
police and I thought actually you know
he's got really good point do you feel
that it's something that you know around
the black lives matters protest we
talked about an awful lot and now it's
almost dropped off the agenda and it's
something that we do still need to be
really considerate about I think it's a
really really important issue and
actually young black men are
um disproportionately represented in the
in the criminal justice system
um and very often that's because they're
more likely to be stops and surged than
uh than the white young men for for
example
um and more needs to be done you know I
was a teenager in the
um in the 1990s when Stephen Lawrence
was murdered for for example
um so I know that distrust sounds I know
for my own constituency some of the
distrust that there is in the police
there is some work that's been going on
to try and sell some Innovations but I
feel the pace of change is not fast
enough what do you think could happen
then well I mean one of the things that
that labor wants to do is introduce the
race equalities act to look at all of
these issues
um uh and some of the structural issues
in society which means that race is
still a a big a big issue okay and thank
you very much great to have you on the
program first time uh we've had you here
so thanks so much thank you
a bit more detail to bring you now on
the breaking news that we're bringing
you uh this evening that is a police
officer has been shot in County Tyrone
in Northern Ireland now the officer was
attacked at a sports complex on the
killer Road in Omar that's according to
security sources and the officer was
shot a number of times we don't know if
they were on duty at the time now a
member of the Ulster unions party at MLA
Tom Elliott has indicated that the
police officer was shot in front of
young people at a football coaching
session
and the DP MP for Belfast East Gavin
Robinson has tweeted thoughts and
prayers with the officer in Omar and all
of his colleagues in Police Service
Northern Ireland they serve us all in
the face of real and present danger
tonight's actions were utterly and
inexcusably reprehensible
you're watching the take we're live in
Westminster for you up next this evening
we're going to be hearing from the party
that likely holds the key to a Northern
Ireland approach called deal the
Democratic unions party that is up next
[Music]
foreign
welcome back live to Westminster you're
watching the take well as we've been
discussing this evening Northern
Ireland's largest unionist party is
likely to hold the key to Rishi Cena
getting any deal over the protocol
across the line now that is because many
in his own party will look to the dup
when deciding whether to approve any
proposal now this was the Prime Minister
earlier he was responding to the dep
leader Sir Jeffrey Donaldson at Primus
questions I've heard loud and clear when
he says he wants and needs these issues
resolved so that he has a basis to work
with others to restore power sharing and
I know that that is genuine he raised
the question of practical issues and it
is vital that these are addressed but he
also raises Mr Speaker a vital question
about the Constitutional and legal
framework in which these Arrangements
exist and I can assure him that I agree
addressing the Democratic deficit is an
essential part of the negotiations that
remain ongoing with the European Union
and just as he has been consistent so
have I and I can assure him that this is
at the very heart of the issues that
must be addressed
well that's the Prime Minister a little
uh earlier I'm delighted to say that we
do have the dep's health spokesperson at
Jim Shannon on the program today to give
us a bit of light uh into what the dep
are thinking when it comes to brexit
before we get there though I would like
to just reflect a bit on the news that
we've had this morning about the
shooting in Omar what do you know if
anything about what's happened oh well
uh probably think of really sketchy to
be honest
reports are coming through that are a
police officer has been shot I I think I
I I say no more I I know all were very
well I was born there probably don't
know very much about it as a retail but
it was my area where we came from
um almost always been a one of those
historic places for me a a country time
but also the memories of the 29 people
were murdered in that Ira bomb away back
some years ago but um I think we just
first would say my my uh absolute
thoughts prayers of everyone all decent
people are with uh with that family and
hope that things are okay
um but it does perhaps remind us
unfortunately uh that there are evil
people out there who have evil
intentions uh and they don't care who
the targets are and they they involved a
chosen someone who
um was vulnerable at that time uh and
and we just have to pray for for his uh
betterment and and for his healing and
and also for the family yeah really um
reports as you say uh coming out of uh
County Tyrone with the shooting of that
police officer she said the details are
still coming through now
um
do you think it's a reminder of the
fragility of Northern Ireland and the
peace there
I think so if we need to prepare over
the years we've seen a dramatic change
in in life in the province um many
people served in the ultra defense
regiment and the British Army and the
police uh give their contribution give
their lives every myself my own family
we've lost uh loved ones uh dear friends
as well we always remember them never
forget them
um I I think those are they're clear
issues but it tells us what was the past
is like now has terrorism ridges
certainly at hands but it doesn't take a
whole lot of people to to keep it going
and it's quite clear to all of us that
uh from the from the information we give
from the police uh that they're still
doesn't Republicans out there who are
intent upon creating havoc on murder as
they will I mean we had a bomb uh in in
last weekend as well so so there's a
reminder nearly every week of something
I mean our place um are very good their
intelligence Services is excellent they
probably they have infiltrated I suspect
it doesn't to some extent but evil
people can do evil things and tonight
we've been reminded of just art and talk
to us a bit about Omar you were born
there you say it has a history doesn't
it or yeah well yeah a a real uh
um I suppose I always take great
pleasure and tell people to come from
over and Vicki forward the MP by the way
the conservative might be she was born a
number as well so we're to uh uh I'm not
sure that because there's something I'm
not sure what they they're terminology
would be but but uh yeah we're very
proud of our history I I think we we we
often and
um even back in my
um 10 years ago uh what was that was a
city where there was division but of
course in those early days back in then
I think my mother always tells me
Mother's Day one's still living by the
way
um and she always tells me that that uh
the relationship between the two
communities and her days when she was
small and that wasn't yesterday uh was
always good they they had their
differences but they lived together uh
the troubles brought change and brought
difference and brought the dissension uh
and and conflict
um but Uma was always a sharing light I
always thought anyway uh and our
community that could work together and
do well
I want to talk to you a little bit about
uh bricks that we heard there of course
where she's like responding to Jeffrey
Johnson obviously at dep
th how close are we do you think to a
deal that could be acceptable to the DP
um I wish it was I thought I would say
to you yeah reality
um
I I don't see that at this moment
there's our parties are very clear
mandate we fought on Election on it uh
We've uh our mom did to deliver to the
people and we're honest people and I
believe in honestly in politics as our
party does I I think we have to ensure
that what we have as a man did is
delivered with a seven point plan uh
Jeffrey Dawson has given an incredible
leadership and he's very clear and we
had a parliamentary meeting this week
and he was as clear as can be no doubt
seven point plan that's what I need to
address how far are we getting there on
that seven point plan
um 3.5 yeah really halfway you think
then positive people yeah but but it's
not about are we are we three quarters
of the way there are we almost there
you've got to have the whole lot we it's
not a big time there's clear issues when
you heard I heard that what Jeffrey said
beside him uh but I heard uh his comment
and he referred to the the
Constitutional position there's big
issues I mean
I suspected the things that they're able
to address or the the small mechanical
issues the mechanism of how how
something would work you know there's a
small fry ones big issues are
constitutional position the other day
other big massive issue is the European
court of justice Authority must always
lie with West there what's playing with
Westminster not with Brussels final
decision and anything that we don't
agree with has to come back to the
Sovereign part and The Sovereign power
is Westminster you see in English he
said obviously as you're saying there
that it would be unacceptable for EU
laws to be imposed on Northern line and
so that the jurisdiction of the European
courts of Justice a red line if you also
said that the treaty needs to be
Rewritten and frankly the EU isn't going
to agree to that is it so it feels to me
like
there isn't going to be a deal that the
dep will agree to well Sophie I'm the
eternal optimist in life I I always uh
and all my life always uh trying to be
the half-class full person rather than a
half class empty uh and this one I I I I
find it very difficult to see it as half
transfer because I don't see an
agreement imminent
um now uh of course it's imminent I mean
the EU said it won't agree to those
things so it's not it's not going to
happen right uh well well if the EU
don't uh um adjust their their demands
in a way that gives us as part of the
United Kingdom the same rights uh I
always I said it today and and the
comments and I always remember Margaret
Thatcher's comments where she said you
know uh Ulster is as British eventually
well no it's not not anymore under the
present agreement so I want to see us
having the same rights in Northern
Ireland as they have in in London and
Cardiff in Plymouth and Newcastle and
indeed and and Edinburgh in Glasgow as
well I guess the difficulty right is if
the UK isn't part of the European Union
anymore there needs to be a border right
where is that order going to be well I I
mean we were able in the past to Harbor
the border on land where we use the
United Kingdom were part uh we in
Northern were part of the United Kingdom
I think that's where where there's going
to be a border that's where it needs to
be not down down there on the island of
Ireland yes I mean that is going to be
for many people just something that they
would never count on us because of the
history right yeah yeah but I think
we've got to remember shortly that the
the border that was was a very poorest
Border in a way I mean very very few
custom checks on it but it doesn't
matter at the time did it because we
were part of this single Market yeah but
but uh I'm I'm old enough uh to uh as a
child but my mum and daughter and my dad
said I know my mother's still living and
she's old enough to remember the Border
we my dad was from Donegal my mother was
from Claudio were uh I say strabane so
the the Border was I know there's a
difference of the of the Northern
Ireland and the Republic of Ireland but
let's be honest it was never that hard
there's a way of doing things I think we
look there's always a solution the
solution is lies with Europe and it lies
clearly the balls of their toes we're
going to play football and they've got a
they've got a pair right I want to talk
to you a little bit about number 10
numbers you see Nick and because it does
it does make me wonder whether there's
been a bit of political naivety here
from uh number 10 do you think they
should have involved the dup a bit
earlier I guess in some of these
discussions
um
well yes
yeah yeah they should have uh to
suddenly uh descend uh um from on high
uh in Belfast and Freddie uh Freddie
last week uh with the conceived plan
that they thought that they could then
deliver without us knowing in any
discussions any talks with what was
going on
um I I look and I would wish Richie soon
like well I I hope and pray that he can
uh deliver an agreement but the reality
is I mean so far we don't
uh include the main participants in in
the process and it's not a visit on a
Friday without with a chopping ring with
five parties they tell them oh by the
way guys here's what I've got uh what do
you think uh no well I'll tell you what
we're quite clear but we think seven
point plan address the issue of the
European court of justice and ensure
that we're as British as British in
Northern Ireland which I don't just feel
my concerns don't feel that a union or
stormfree at this moment
I guess some people on the opposite side
of the argument might be thinking look
the current situation there are issues
with the current situation right now
someone is even functioning there isn't
even a functioning government in
Northern Ireland isn't it time for the
dup to compromise a bit as well are you
making perfect enemy of good
um we're starting off with good so I'm
not making any perfect anime of good
because we we believe that uh We've
commanded to deliver our constitution
business so do you have a mandate to
deliver you don't have a majority on the
assembly in favor of the protocol well
we have and within the unions every
unionist that there is at the Northern
Ireland assembly are opposed to the
protocol so from a union Tony Blair two
examples Tony Blair
uhern uh both of them have said there
can be no deal without a participation
and full involvement of unionists up
until now we haven't had that film
involvement so I think we we're at a
stage where where
um if prominent
politicians here and our and and the
United Kingdom but also in Ireland are
indicating that we have to be part of
that process you can deliver whatever
you want if Government voices to but if
we aren't bought into that process the
universe people aren't born in that
process there's a stem for failure and
now I want to ask you the question that
David Bevins tested to me uh when I said
that you were coming on he said I should
ask you what do you regret the most
supporting brexit which meant that they
would have to be a border somewhere or
not voting for The Theresa May deal when
you have the chance
and I heard you and I heard him I I was
second or better than and and hear from
the city and I don't want to say we're
all in and we're all right sort of okay
you can't make your mind on my own I'm
out and figure it all about I saw how it
works uh we're all uh part of the United
Kingdom we're Britain North now within
brexit or we're not all together so I my
answer to that one is uh uh we we wish
to be I I love my business I I whenever
I first came to to Parliament Islands
one of the first guys it's always
referred people referred the United
Kingdom I always referred to the United
Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland and that Mantra and words were a
reminder to money on the chamber it's
very very much hospital is for me it's
not for making students so uh and what
to regret the most well neither were
good and for not good then they're not
we're not going to buy on debt so um
we're not in but we want to be alongside
what they what Boris Johnson and and his
consents have in London and and what
they have in Newcastle and what album
Cardiff what happened Glasgow in
Edinburgh is that too much to ask for
the Union's population this can never
succeed if there's no buy-in from
unionism okay thank you very much thank
you thank you very much
uh a reminder now of the breaking news
that we're bringing you this evening
that is that's an off-duty police
officer has been shot in County Tyrone
in Northern Ireland now security sources
say the officer was attacked at a sports
complex in Omar the officer was shot a
number of times and Ulster unionist
party MLA Tom Elliott has indicated that
the police officer was shot in front of
young people at a football coaching
session at that breaking news that we're
bringing you that this evening well
that's it for the take we'll be back
next week
[Music]